one particular series that shows up in
many applications examples or problems
is the geometric series the geometric
series were given a certain number alpha
and we want to sum all the powers of
alpha starting from the zeroth power
which is equal to 1 the first power and
so on and this gives us an infinite
series it's the sum of alpha to the I
where I ranges from zero to infinity now
for this series to converge we need
subsequent terms the different terms in
the series to become smaller and smaller
and for this reason we're going to make
the assumption that the number alpha is
less than 1 in magnitude which implies
that consecutive terms go to 0 let us
introduce some notation let us denote
the infinite sum by s and we're going to
use that notation shortly one way of
evaluating this series is to start from
an algebraic identity namely the
following let us take 1 minus alpha and
multiply it by the terms in the series
but going only up to the term alpha to
the N so it's a finite series we do this
multiplication we get a bunch of terms
we do the cancellations and what is left
at the end is 1 minus alpha to the power
n plus 1 what we do next is we take the
limit as n goes to infinity on the left
hand side we have the term 1 minus alpha
and then the limit of this finite series
is by definition the infinite series
which we are denoting by s on the right
hand side we have the term 1 how about
this term since alpha is less than 1 in
magnitude this converges to 0 as alpha
goes to infinity so that term disappears
we can now solve this relation and we
obtain that s is equal to 1 over 1 minus
alpha and this is the formula for the
infinite geometric series there's
another way of deriving the same result
which is interesting so let us go
through it as well
the infinite geometric series has one
first term and then the remaining terms
which is a sum for I going from 1 to
infinity of alpha to the I now we can
take a factor of alpha out of this
infinite sum and write it as 1 plus
alpha the sum of alpha to the I but
because we took out one factor of alpha
here we're going to have smaller powers
so now the sum starts from 0 and goes up
to infinity now this is just 1 plus
alpha times s because here we have the
infinite geometric series therefore if
we subtract alpha s from both sides of
this equality we get s times 1 minus
alpha equal to 1 and now by moving one
minus alpha to the denominator we get
again the same expression so this is an
alternative way of deriving the same
result however there's one word of
caution in this step we subtracted alpha
s from both sides of the equation and in
order to do that this is only possible
if we take for granted that s is a
finite number so this is taken for
granted in order to carry out this
derivation this is to be contrasted with
the first derivation in which we didn't
have to make any such assumption so
strictly speaking for this derivation
here to be correct we need to have some
independent way of verifying that s is
less than infinity but other than that
it's an interesting algebraic trick